hi there this is Steve co-founder of
Lync someone who is enjoying learning
languages I learned about nine of them
up to the age of sixty and I've learned
another nine in the last ten or so years
and I know very well that in language
learning first of all everyone can do it
everyone can do it it doesn't take a
special talent although you get better
the more languages you learn and it
consists of three absolutely important
keys the first one is your attitude
are you interested do you like the
language do you like learning it do you
believe in the system do you think
you're gonna get there you have to be
positive that's the first the second of
all you have to spend the time find the
time
listen ten minutes here fifteen minutes
there you have to find the time and work
on your links and the third thing is
developing the ability to notice what's
happening in the language but that comes
if you have the attitude if you spend
the time you will start to notice the
language and you are going to learn take
it from me